how the gun rise whoa my name is back
welcome back this by that so the cop
just bailed on me Oh bro bro no ah fine
I'm all alone again aren't I oh my god
well trying to open the door
how do I stop stop oh yeah yeah no it's
a weird controls in this game alright
you're a handsome fella I was told that
I could switch to like first-person view
but no one actually told me how to
switch to first stop jumping man Oh fine
keep jumping man put cha cha cha cha
that's right boxes ain't got [ __ ] on me
bro alright stop Willie Miguel won't
talk to you I'm not trying okay no Jesus
Kyle just shut up I won't do that good
huh hey whoa hope you're okay man I wish
I knew how to change
I feel like this clicking every freaking
button on there that urinal looks like
it
happy face if these is a god than was
here joy can I take this up all right
yeah what what all right all right one
day I was told that you can slice these
slices slices dices right it doesn't
seem like it all right now what the hell
Wow anyone in here huh go bury it
everywhere I like that my tastes doing
that [ __ ] breathing keep getting a mo
but no [ __ ] whoa anyone out there
another flashlight
I don't want the phone thank you [ __ ]
don't close doors on me man yeah that's
barek what pretty well lit up whoa whoa
no now what the [ __ ] where did he go
Holly to take a pee the question is why
I'm following him hey man you in here
good all right so I have flash I [ __ ]
breathing is so disturbing
all right more drugs and alcohol that's
cool hey there officer I know why I did
that but whoa what oh it's a statue with
all right cool come on man [ __ ] yeah it
is
you got a blade and [ __ ] whoa stop
people whoa all right we got power whoa
I need something it's chicken here I
guess
whoa all right you're looking good
you're looking sexy all right bring it
whoa actually please don't all right
nice meeting you [ __ ] was that good fun
oh come on
don't tease me with that body let's open
this I said open oh I get it
it's a puzzle oh no one open and one
what are you doing hey man you're
ruining the sister come on
not cool you don't [ __ ] with the system
and I want to fight you
ah [ __ ] me I got you all right
you speak Japanese I don't all right
Chuck top don't block block whoa nice
light bro where the [ __ ] did he go whoa
whoa whoa whoa [ __ ] you why don't you
bleed [ __ ] fake fights going on here
I think something is wrong with the
sound
[Music]
[ __ ] you I'm [ __ ] tourists bro that's
right bro stop fool it's good if thought
you were dead all of you out
[ __ ] masks and [ __ ] I talked to this
handsome guy that paper [ __ ] with me
no look I'm a period ish now [ __ ] period
man [ __ ] it I might do it no no no I
don't want to click it ha ha puzzles are
better all right bro I need you to step
aside anyway hey yeah I just met you and
this is crazy but you are handsome oh no
no no no no no [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that
guy not going there
there's no [ __ ] jump [ __ ] die did not
see that
why come on I don't want to with him
this game is not scary they said play
this game hey hiya done I like what you
did
Oh sighs its Isis Isis Isis Isis Isis
Isis AIT's a garage like about like
about them talk [ __ ] I'm talk I
spin that the Japanese betcha or not
right Aurora what the hell is going on
here
a spirit the [ __ ] is it green for it
oh no I know what it's gonna do with
them someone farted probably probably
the green line I didn't fire its way oh
I gotta save him all right I'll do that
how I wait if I could bro I swear it
doesn't work bro what do I do bro
hey come on okay
hey I just met you I had this [ __ ]
song in the rain maybe this is where the
gases
all right whoa hey bro I'm really sorry
all right drains me press Mouse 5 or tab
I don't think guns whoa no no no no no
no no no brick okay actually do it hey
Thank You Brad ha ha de brazza oh no he
comes back all right whoa whoa [ __ ]
Brandon oh oh it's a boss fight what's
on it spoke Japanese before you were
born bro revolver ammo where's your
mother
I'll slice her up your lady good girl
[ __ ] you ah [ __ ] it sounds it's just not
working I have to fix it or is it
working I don't [ __ ] know interface I
kill your mama boy kill your mama kill
her
the monster designs are awesome in this
game the sound though not really it's
pretty intimidating now all right have
it god I can't dodge cycle no no no no
do you do it do what take away man's
light and clothes and food and his
friends and it right here bro right here
you know why we put it off forever
this place is stronger than you nothing
come on that guy is not cool I don't
like Hey look at I everywhere no torque
we're in trouble bro but you got the
side road going so it's ok this looks
like a puzzle area to be quite honest
[Music]
come on talk no good time
alright the Green Man is one of our
trees here but the final solution
one of the few full admit that why first
didn't give it
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow yeah porgies like come on man I a
long time understand much about this
place but I know you'll being here ain't
no coincidence all right
I don't usually take advice for someone
who's in the electric box by a shot a
lot
you remember the guy the holograph seen
Jess right
it's don't buy your life you sick
bastard put me to shame I never got to
snuff a woman know now that I'm really
do it because we get innocent guys in
here sure listen until presumed guilty
you [ __ ] you know that accreted to
the war line compares to the
dissatisfaction of terrain well wonder
wife but you already know that don't you
I don't know anything I didn't care that
any one bra weird game bra you had a
wife right come on why would you go to
make sure she stayed yours I'll get mad
you feel you could kill a man rip them
apart with your bare hands I don't know
what you're talking about Phil that way
no maybe not like you say you came from
nowhere I hate you I [ __ ] through my
mouth you are creepy I ain't you I'll
slice you until you're dead
I can give you control you let go my
baby shut ah here in here I wanna know
all about you all right there we go
Here I am baby what what that Hey
I'm bad at slap that all on the floor
dude give me some more
see it alright
oh it drains my health to be this guy
alright hey and they're all right it's a
lot for me to with anyway it's pretty
cool game I you have seen flaws but I
know it so far but it's pretty fun and
Lee anyway like a favor if you enjoyed
subscribe to come bro today and I'll see
you next episode away links
all right now money simply Jack run and
never